Hồ quan trích chính quyền Mỹ Sát Nhật, nhà trắng đang hoàn tất dự thảo sách lạnh hành phát,
nhằm sết chặt kìm xóa ca hành vi cinh đọc bạo lực chính trị và ngôn từ thủ hành.
Đây là phản nứng trực tiếp xa vô ám sát nhỏ đậu bảo thủ trắng li khó,
sự kiện đã làm giới lên những trình luận đầy khác,
khi hơn 1 chăm 2 mấy tổ chức phía lệ nhận,
bong ông Gui Ford, Gui Opens Society và Gui Ec Khân Nguy,
đặt kiế thư Trung phản đối, khẳng định bản chất tự thiệt,
và kêu hỏi chính phủ không chính trị hoàn hoạt động sảo hội dân dự.
Tế sợ đó, chúng ta một tình bố đưa đăng tài trên nền tàng tru sâu sâu,
tầm thông trông tiền bố chính tức trị đình,
ăn trị phà, một phân trào chống phá sế, là một tổ chức khủ bố,
đồng tường những mạnh sẽ đi nghị đến anh điều tra tàng diện,
những cá nhân và tổ chức tài trở cho phòng trào này,
một cách nghiêm ngấm nhất,
tự bố mọi nhát của tầm thống mấy đứa ra trong uối cạnh,
vẫn chưa có bằng chính trứ thấy nghĩ phạm ám sát ông Chòi Khân,
có liên quan đến mất tìm của tổ chức nào.